مي عرض مغر من النيتو لاوكرانيا لانهاء
الحرب وكيا ترفض وموسكو ترد بسخريه فما هو
العرض يا ترى بوتين يز دوله في النيتو
للمره الاولى منذ بدايه الحرب فما الذي
يدور من تحت الطاوله الدفاع الاوكرانيه
اوكرانيا اكبر قنبله ملغومه على وجه الارض
وان لم يتصرف الحلفاء فستن لع الكارثه
موسكو تعلن ان سياسه صب الزيت على النار
الغربيه تجر دولا اخرى الى مصير اوكرانيا
يا الهي اني اجتم رائحه بولندا لترد وارس
باستعراض ضخم لعضلاته وكما اخبرناكم في
الفيديو السابق ها هو بوتين يبدا اول خطوه
لالتهام الدوله التاليه بعد النيجر منظومه
النرويج تجلب الحل كياف لمشكله المسيرات
الروسيه والانقلاب في النيجر يحضر نهايه
قاسيه ل بازوم وواشنطن تحذر وبشده اصحاب
العيون الضيقه يحققون قفزه نوعيه بعالم
صناعه الاسلحه اذهلت امريكا عرض مغر
لاوكرانيا الذخائر تنتهي والقوى تخور
والعزائم تتراجع ومع كل يوم جديد يواجه
الغرب خسائر قاسيه والغربيون لم تعد لديهم
طاقه يا ساده ليقدم مدير المكتب الخاص
لامين عام حلف الناتو سيتيان جونسون عرضا
رابحا لاوكرانيا لانهاء الازمه من جذورها
وذلك بقوله ان اوكرانيا يمكن ان تنضم
للحلف مقابل التنازل عن جزء من اراضيها
لروسيا هل ترونه اقتراحا عادلا لا سما مع
خساره كياف المزيد من الاراضي مع مضي
الوقت كياف ردت فورا واعلن مستشار رئيس
مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بودل ياك
ان كياف لن تستبدل الاراض بعضويه النيتو
وانتهز الفرصه كعاده المسؤولين في نظام
كياف للمطالبه بتسريع ارسال السلاح لهم
فيال صبر الغربيين على نظام كياف ورغبتهم
بطاحه الحرب وكان الغرب يقول هم طولك يا
روح و بس ومن الجانب الروسي اعتبر نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديميتري مدفيدف
انه من اجل دخول اوكرانيا الى النيتو يجب
على سلطات البلاد التخلي عن كياف نفسها
لان جميع اراضيها محل نزاع يا لثقتك يا
هذا وبعوده الى اوكرانيا قال وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اوليكس ريزنيكوف لصحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيه ان اوكرانيا اصبحت
اكثر دوله ملغومه على وجه الارض ونشد
ريزنيكوف الدول حليفه سرعه التقديم معدات
حديثه وتدريب الخبراء الاوكرانيين للتعامل
مع حقول الالغام الروسيه التي تنتشر على
مساحه شاسعه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه والان
ننتقل الى الميدان حيث قال الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي ان القوات
الروسيه ضربت منطقه خرص بوحشيه خلال ساعات
الامر الذي اسفر عن سقوط قتلى وجرحى وفق
تعبيره مضيفا ان هذا لن يمر دون رد فيما
اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه ان وحده الجيش
الروسي بالتعاون مع القوات الفنيه والجويه
التابعه للمجموعه العسكريه الروسيه فوستوك
دمرت اكثر من 20 موقعا قتاليا للقوات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه وكالعاده لابد من
مصدر وها نحن نستع الضربات الروسيه التي
استهدفت بهجمات صاروخيه خلال الليل عده
مناطق مخلفه اضرارا في البنى التحتيه
للمدينه من جهه اخرى قال مسؤولون محليون
ان مدينه لفيف الاوكرانيه تعرضت لقصف يف
مما ادى الى تضرر اكثر من 100 شقه سكنيه
واصابه اربعه اشخاص قالت مصادر اوكرانيه
ان الجيش الروسي اطلق ما لا يقل عن 28
صاروخا من انواع مختلفه صوب الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وتمكنت قوات الدفاع الجوي من
اسقاط 16 منها الارقام كبيره والمصادر
تتحدث اقت روسيا ما لا يقل عن 28 صاروخ
هذه الصواريخ استهدفت وسط اوكرانيا وايضا
غربي اوكرانيا قتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصيب
ثلاثه اخرين لنختم اخبار المعارك باعلان
الدفاع الروسي مقتل اكثر من 800 جندي
اوكراني خلال يوم كما افادت بان دفاعاتها
الجويه اسقطت ولاول مره منذ بدء الحرب
اربعه صواريخ مجنحه بعيده المدى فرنسيه
الصنع من طراز سكالب او جي والعهده على
المصدر كما هو واضح من موقع الحكومه
الروسيه ونحن لا نؤكد ولا نن فيه ومن
رائحه البارود وضجيج الرصاص والمدافع الى
الحرب الناعمه عن السياسه نتحدث اذ ان
الرئيس الروسي بوتين سيزور دوله بالناتو
للمره الاولى منذ بدايه الحرب الاوكرانيه
ووفقا لصحيفه ميلي التركيه فان انقره تامل
بان يقوم الرئيس بوتين بزياره الى تركيا
في الايام القريبه القادمه فما الذي يخطط
له بوتين من زياره كهذا لتتواصل الحرب
الناعمه من طرف حيث اكد وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شويجو ان القوات الروسيه
العسكريه بدات في الانهيار والتلاشي وان
الغرب يواصل دعمها بالاسلحه وتقويض الامن
الدولي هاهم الغربيون يؤكدون حديث شويجو
وذلك باعلان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن عن حزمه مساعدا امنيه جديده
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 200 مليون دولار واوضح
بلينكن ان هذه المساعدات تتضمن ذخائر
للدفاع الجوي وطلقات مدفعيه ومعدات مضاده
للدروع وغيرها فعن اي سخاء نتحدث بينما
مصير كل هذه الاسلحه معلوم في ذات السياق
اعلنت الحكومه النرويجيه ومجموعه كونسبت
للدفاع والفضاء عزمهما تزويد اوكرانيا
بمنظومات جديده مضاده للطائرات المسيره
لتحييد مسيرات موسكو بتمويل من حلفاء كياف
بقيمه 65 مليون يورو وفي تقرير لرويترز
نقلا عن وزير الدفاع السويدي بول
ذكرت الوكاله ان السويد تعتزم تزويد
اوكراني بحزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده بقيمه
313.5 مليون دولار والتي ستتضمن بشكل
اساسي ذخيره وقطع غيار لانظمه الاسلحه
التي تم تسليمها سابقا وها نحن نعود الى
بوتين والذي اكد حديثنا عن قطعه الجاتو
الكبرى بعد النيجر حيث بدا الرئيس الروسي
اول خطوه ليضع قدما له هناك في الساحل
وذلك بمهاتفة
الحشود بالعاصمه البولنديه لرؤيه دبابات
ابرامز وانظمه المدفعيه المتنقله هيمارس
وصواريخ باتريوت امريكيه الصنه الى جانب
طائرات اف اي 50 المقاتله المصنوعه في
كوريا الجنوبيه ومدافع هازار وتجدر
الاشاره الى ان عمليات تحديث الجيش
البولندي عززت قدرات البلاد الدفاعيه وقد
حل العتاد الجديد محل اسلحه ومعدات
سوفيتيه وروسيه الصنع قدمتها بولندا
لاوكرانيا الاحداث والت تطورات بعد تواعد
قاده الانقلاب العسكري في النيجير بمحاكمه
الرئيس محمد بزوم بتهم الخيانه العظمى
وتقوي امن البلاد قال نائب المتحدث باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه فيدانت باتل ان
التهديد بمحاكمه رئيس النيجر محمد بزم عمل
غير مبرر واهانه للديمقراطيه واضاف بطل ان
ذلك لن يساعد في ايجاد حل سلمي للازمه في
النيجر فيما اكد المتحدث باسم البنتاغون
باتريك رايدر ان واشنطن لديها اي نيه لسحب
قواتها من النيجر مشيرا الى انها تراقب
الوضع عن كثب في هذا البلد من جانبها
اعتبرت الجماعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا ايكواس ان اعلان العسكريين
الانقلابيين نيتهم محاكمه بازوم بتهمه
الخيانه العظمى يشكل استفزازا جديدا توصل
باحثون الصينيون الى اختراق كبير بعالم
صناعه الاسلحه حيث اكدوا انهم استطاعوا
ايجاد حل لعمل اسلحه الليزر التي كانت
تواجه بعض المشاكل واوضحت صحيفه ديلي ميل
البريطانيه هذا النوع من الاسلحه يمتلئ
بالحراره الزائده اثناء كل استخدام مما
يجبر المشغلين على ايقاف التشغيل حتى
يسترجع برودته